fans of the Speed Racer known as the
fastest woman on four wheels say they
are just devastated by her death in a
jet car accident 39 year old Jessie
Combs was trying to break the woman's
land speed record when she crashed in
the Oregon desert on Tuesday CBS this
morning Saturday co-host Dana Jacobson
is here with more on this story Dana
people keep saying who knew her that she
was so full of life and lived life
really to its fullest so what happened
yeah well Gail they're still
investigating that crash right now but
Combs who was known widely in this niche
sport of jet racing died doing what she
loved her boyfriend told CBS News that
the world lost a brave woman doing
things typically dominated by men like
racing and welding Jessi combs broke
barriers six years ago she set a land
speed record for a woman on four wheels
driving 398 miles per hour with a
modified jet engine but Tuesday in
Oregon she crashed while attempting to
go more than 500 miles per hour in an
Instagram post Sunday about her record
breaking attempt Combs wrote people say
I'm crazy I say thank you motorsports
and racing tends to be a male-dominated
industry and Jessi really worked to be
an inspiration to women and girls
beyond racing Combs was also known as a
TV personality from shows like all girls
garage and Mythbusters it's time to
bring in the big guns
Jessi was an incredibly competent woman
in what is largely a boys club
former Mythbusters co-host Adam Savage
the ways in which she was inspiring to
young engineers and she really took that
position seriously she wanted to inspire
people like her when she was young to
try the things that they couldn't
believe they would get to do an
accomplished artist and crafts woman as
well as speed demon and daredevil Combs
lived her life boldly people like Jessi
are rare in the world and we need more
and I'm very sad that she's gone very
well said in a post this year combs
wrote I'm just a girl who likes to ride
motorcycles build rad things out of
metal race anything I can have great
conversations laugh a lot weld stuff
break stereotypes go on adventures push
the limits and have fun while I do it
she ended that by saying don't hate me
because I'm awesome you know what she
could write a little bit too I like that
do you need more like it especially for
someone who didn't know her you hear
about anything sure would have liked to
have met her whatever firecracker of a
personality yeah and our colleague Jamie
yuccas had a chance to talk with her
boyfriend yesterday and he said she had
so many things that she wanted to do and
people she wanted to influence that he
wants to keep that going for her very
sad news Dana thank you very much